I still don't like
the resolution on these images.
>> Darn it.
Yeah, a lot of people have been
commenting about how the sheep just
don't look real enough.
[SOUND]
>> And didn't your investors say
something about wanting you to
identify a larger target audience?
>> Yeah, well, maybe.
I'm starting to wonder if Bale Buddy
is going to be the destructive and
transformative app that
I originally dreamed of.
>> There might not be enough
shepherds in the Bay Area.
It's too small a market.
Baa, hey,
don't bleat yourself up about it.
>> Ha-ha, real funny.
All right, well,
back to the drawing board.
Let's see.
I'm thinking some sort of
app maybe about like, crap.
Walter, did you forget
the whiteboard markers again?
>> I just went to the store,
you should've told me this earlier.
Kagure had the same problem yesterday
when we needed toilet paper and WD40.
>> Yeah, it goes both ways.
I was at the store picking up these
cheesy flakes, they were on sale.
And then, Walter did the same thing.
But you know what,
I have dinner for next week.
[LAUGH]
>> Can't be good for your credit score.
>> Crap, I'm running out of gas money.
This is super inconvenient.
[SOUND] If only there was some
way that we could communicate,
something collaborative, that would
be right there in the store with you,
something like an app.
Great Scott, I've got an idea.